[Applause]
all right so that is so kind of you and
I am hesitant to say that the president
is it a new low cuz you'll think it's a
repeat
it's not at October 20th 2017 a week for
the history books also for the books
about abnormal psychology so here's what
America was debating about this week on
Monday Trump called the pregnant widow
of a dead American soldier to console
her and wound up pouring salt in the
wound and feuding with her all week
who knew epithelial occator I mean if
you could take a week where it was
revealed that Harvey Weinstein sexually
assaulted every single female in show
business and still be the worst fat
gross creep
and you know all of this came in bad
pick is the same Trump pattern Bluff lie
attack because you know he doesn't know
anything so when he's asked about
something he's got a bluff and then when
they call him out man they call him on
the bluff then he lies and then when
they call him on the why he attacks so
this is exactly what happened three
weeks ago four of our Green Berets were
killed in the African country of Nigeria
Trump didn't say anything for two weeks
but someone put him on the spot about it
last week so he bluffed and said I wrote
them letters of course he didn't we
didn't even know about them because they
didn't do anything that would get on his
radar like kneel at a football game
calm down bill room two minutes into
this story I'm gonna put there my head's
gonna explode anyway but then he says
forget the letters I was just waiting
for the right time to call which in the
case of the widow of Sergeant David
Johnson turned out to be when she was in
the car going to the airport to accept
the body this is when Trump thinks it is
a good time to say to her he knew what
he signed up for somewhere Rex Tillerson
is saying I told you he was immoral and
then Trump drags General John Kelly his
chief of staff into this because Kelly's
own son was killed in Afghanistan and
opala never called so he sends out Cali
yesterday to defend his own inept call
and stupid lies and I feel bad for
general Kelly having to defend this vile
nincompoop on the on the other hand he
knew what he signed up for
now look I know general Kelly is the
only thing that stands between Utz and
World War 3 but this was not his finest
hour he spent a lot of time smearing
this congresswoman who was in the car
doing her job and she was a friend
supporting the widow when Trump's call
came in so Kelly does what Republicans
always do they invent new rules I
thought I had new rules now they have
new words like like you know if you if
you criticize the president overseas it
insults the troops oh is that yeah we
that's always been no they did so he
vents his new rule a phone call from a
president to a widow is sacred and if it
comes on a speakerphone you can't listen
in first of all she wasn't listening in
she didn't tap the woman's phone she
happened to be in the car and also what
kind of [ __ ] in the whole history of
the world has ever had to deny something
he said during a condolence call
so then general Kelly laments a short
list of things that would always in his
in his youth he said we always thought
would be sacred but no longer are and he
says women gold star families above all
this is what we should hold sacred women
and gold star families now flick scuse
me I need to get back to defending my
boss the [ __ ] grabber who insults war
widows and it actually gets worse
because of this subject coming up we
found out this week that back in June
Trump was on a condolence call to a
father of someone who died and
apparently was so moved by his pledge he
said I'm going to do what no presidents
ever done I'm gonna write you a personal
check for $25,000 and then never sent it
or what he calls the art of the deal
you know he needs that 25 grand because
this happened this week Donald Trump
dropped ninety two spots on the Forbes
list of richest Americans
he was also dropped to number two on
Forbes list of disgusting sex predators
the right wing I doubt that he is
adorable pleased harvey whites to you
but the right wing media frenzy over
harvey weinstein i tell you the men of
foxnews are like those of us who are
left here are outraged you know it is
important to remember why all this
sideshows [ __ ] is going on yeah you know
real policy moves are being made that
affect all of our lives i mean this just
this week trump's trying to dismantle
Obama's Iran deal Obama's clean power
plan one guy I know which is Eric you
brought a friend
trying to of course get rid of Obamacare
I mean everything Obama touched has got
to go
you know this Confederate statues in the
South that are such an eyesore it's too
bad Obama didn't put them up because
they'd all be gone by now let's say I'm
not a happy note I know Angelina's are
thrilled it's not my team but the
Dodgers are in the World Series so
[Applause]
though the Dodgers are such a favorite
to win they've already declined their
invitation to the White House a new
folks around the country you know if
you're gonna watch the World Series a
Dodger fans are notorious for showing up
late and leaving early like Trump in
Puerto Rico